Und ich bin schon dran.
Wir haben mal eine Sendung gemacht über RFID-Chips und wo die überall schon drin sind. Und da rief, und das fand ich damals total cool, und da fand ich es auch cool, dass wir solche Hörer haben, da rief ein Hörer an und sagte so, naja, also ich will euch ja jetzt nicht beunruhigen, aber diese RFID-Chips, also wir nähen die seit Jahren in unsere Klamotten ein. Wir machen nämlich so hochqualitative Klamotten beziehungsweise Sachen, die einfach viel kosten, so Designerzeug und wir packen das in unsere Jackets, und zwar in jedes einzelne. Und da waren alle ziemlich überrascht und das war eine ziemlich coole Geschichte. Daran erinnere ich mich immer gerne zurück.
Wir haben sehr viel gesprochen über Bundestrojaner, über Überwachung und solche Geschichten und da habe ich viel auch noch dazugelernt, was ich nicht wusste. Ich kannte zwar so von der Oberfläche, was da so passiert, aber wir sind in den Sendungen natürlich sehr intensiv eingestiegen. Zum Beispiel, wo es um RFID-Chips ging und RFID-Funktechnik, wie weit so ein Ding auslesbar ist. Und dass ich theoretisch, wenn ich ein Lesegerät in der Tasche habe und du stehst fünf Meter von mir weg, dass ich eigentlich auslesen könnte, was du in der Tasche hast. Das fand ich schon ganz schön spooky in einer gewissen Weise. Ich fand auch die Sendung zum Big Brother Awards immer wieder spannend, weil man also gucken kann, welche Firmen Schindluder treiben mit Daten. Das taucht ja immer wieder auf. Und das, was wir damals so besprochen hatten und was so ein bisschen als Zukunftsmusik damals galt, hat sich ja in den letzten Jahren durchaus als Realität und nur ein Bruchteil dessen, was wahrscheinlich wirklich da ist, gezeigt. Snowden, solche Geschichten sind ja nur der Anfang. Wir hatten eine sehr spannende Sendung zu Wikileaks, die ich sehr interessant fand, wo Leute berichtet haben, wie sie an diese Daten rankommen und wie unter welchen auch persönlichen Repressalen in solche Geschichten an das Netz gestellt werden, um diese freie Information der Öffentlichkeit zugänglich zu machen. Das fand ich sehr spannend.
Speziell in der nach Snowden Zeit ist es natürlich schon immer wieder faszinierend zurückzudenken an die ganzen Gespräche mit den Mitgliedern vom Chaos Computer Club, die teilweise doch ein bisschen paranoid wirkten, also die ja schon vor vielen, vielen Jahren schon ganz häufig dazu geraten haben, Mails zu verschlüsseln, auf Sicherheit im Internet zu achten, was man wie wann, wo von sich gibt, ob man das unter Klarnamen machen sollte oder nicht. Also diese ganzen Debatten hatten wir ja. Und das war alles lange vor Twitter, lange vor Facebook und lange, lange, lange vor Snowden. Und interessant von heute aus zu sehen ist natürlich schon, dass vieles von dem, was Außenstehende vielleicht als paranoid bezeichnet hätten oder auch so angesehen haben, alles andere als paranoid war, sondern dass an dem doch eine Menge dran war und ist und bleibt.
Der Club hat, und damit halt auch die Sendung, im Grunde zu einer Haltungsänderung bei mir geführt. Ich kann auch gar nicht immer so genau sagen, welche Haltung ich vorher hatte und welche ich danach hatte, aber es ist sicherlich ein Gutteil Skeptizismus in mich hineingekommen durch den Club. Ja, ich sehe mit Sicherheit die Welt auf eine andere Weise, als ich sie gesehen habe, bevor ich mit dem Club involviert war. Aber ich könnte nicht an Detail benennen, auf welche Weise das ist. Es ist eine bessere Weise, als ich es vorher gesehen habe. Also ich gehe mit anderen Augen durch die Welt, mit ein bisschen wacheren Augen.
Ziemlich große Dinge, die hier bewegt worden sind durch das Chaosradio, was ihr gerade hier hört. Chaosradio Folge 200 aus der Marienstraße 11 in Berlin, aus dem Chaos Computer Club Berlin. Und zu Gast auf dem Gastsofa, das ihr euch noch angucken könnt, sind jetzt zusätzlich zu FIFA auch noch THS. Hallo und guten Abend. Und Artort.
Schönen guten Abend.
So ihr beiden, was war denn eigentlich eure erste Sendung, Artort? Was war denn deine erste Sendung, Chaosradio?
Das muss die 43 gewesen sein, zu E-Mail. Ja genau, das war ja in der damaligen Zeit, wie Steini und Tim auch schon ein bisschen angesprochen hatten, da gab es halt diesen, was man heute Think Tank nennen würde, da gab es also diese Berliner Firma, die aus einem Verein hervorgegangen ist und da saßen die halt die ganze Zeit und sprachen über Techniken und ihre gesellschaftspolitischen Auswirkungen. Und einer der Aspekte, der im Club immer auch aufs Tapir gebracht wurde, war, im Verhältnis zum Staat und zur Wirtschaft sind das ja Infrastrukturen, die ich als Bürger, die ich als Individu umnutze. Kann man diese Infrastrukturen nicht verstehen und gegebenenfalls selber betreiben. Und vor dem Hintergrund haben wir damals gesagt, wir erklären mal, was das mit dieser E-Mail ist, die ja, das muss so 97 gewesen sein, noch nicht in dem Maße in der Gesellschaft angekommen war, wie es heute ist.
Und glaubst du, man müsste das heute eigentlich noch mal genauso erklären?
Na machen wir doch.
Okay, Chaosradio 201 E-Mail.
Nö, nicht mit mir, was du jetzt hier schreibst.
Nein, was ich meine ist, ob ihr, das ist sozusagen die Technologie, ist zwar in der Mitte der Gesellschaft angekommen, aber ist auch das Verständnis dafür da mittlerweile?
Das hat sich auf jeden Fall gewandelt. Was für mich den Club immer ausgemacht hat und dann letztlich auch die Motivation war, mitzugehen ins Chaos Radio, als Tim mich eingepackt hat, war immer auch so ein Anspruch, aus dieser Eco-Chamber rauszukommen. Das Tolle am Club war, man konnte über alles diskutieren, aber dazu musste man an einen physischen Ort in Berlin kommen und an diesem physischen Ort mit Leuten diskutieren. Und relativ langsam hat sich dann gezeigt, man kann diese Diskussion natürlich auch auf das Internet führen. Aber was für Meinungsfindungsinstrumente gab es denn zum damaligen Zeitpunkt und die gab es nicht in dem Maße wie heute mit Liquid Feedback, wo ganze Parteien versuchen, ihre Willensbildung darüber abzuwickeln. Das waren ja alles eher so im Entstehen begriffen. Und vor dem Hintergrund scheint es mir schon wichtig, dass wir über das sprechen. Aber der Vorteil am Medium Rundfunk im Vergleich zum Podcast ist sicherlich die Reichweite. Der Vorteil am Podcast ist, dass die Sendezeit nicht begrenzt ist. Also das Schöne am Internet ist, der Platz geht nicht aus. Die Regale sind nie voll. Und insofern glaube ich, dass es für so spezifische Themen, um das in so eine vierstündige Sendung zu machen, eher in einem Podcast sinnvoll ist, während die gesellschaftspolitische Dimension mehr Sinn macht in der Rundfunksendung, weil einfach die Klientel eine ganz andere ist.
Ich habe mit Earthgeist zusammen eine Sendung gemacht über Wi-Fi, über WEP-Verschlüsselungen. Ich weiß nicht mehr den genauen Titel, aber es ging darum, dass diese ganzen WLAN-Hotspots, die überall aufpoppten, alle ziemlich offen und kaputt sind und dass man da ziemlich viel Unfug treiben kann. Und auch mit dem WEP, diese Verschlüsselung, die es damals gab, dass die nicht so besonders brauchbar ist.
Da haben wir uns ja heute richtig Vorwürfe, dass wir das damals erzählt haben. Übrigens, weil jetzt ist Deutschland so eines der letzten Länder, wo es keine offenen WLANs gibt, wo du, wenn du irgendwo Internet brauchst, hast du verloren. Meistens ist dein Handy dabei mit Internet. Und in anderen Ländern gibt es einfach offene WLANs und bei uns sind die alle zu, wegen Störerhaftung und Scheiße. Aber wenn wir das nicht erklärt hätten damals, wie man seine WLANs zu macht, hätten wir jetzt überall kostenlos Internet. Also rückblickend war das immer so zweisteinig mit der Aufklärung.
Gibt es denn noch andere Themen, wo ihr euch ernsthaft im Nachhinein denkt, so, ah, das hätte man vielleicht anders machen müssen? Also sowohl vom Club aus als auch vom Chaosradio vielleicht?
Ja, natürlich die Wahlcomputer einfach zu erzählen, dass die unsicher sind. Wir könnten jetzt die ganze Republik übernehmen.
Und die Störerhaftung abschaffen.
Ja gut, eine verpasste Chance in der Tat. Wir haben ja gerade gehört, was die anderen Moderatoren so gelernt haben in der Sendung. Ist das für euch was Positives?
Was hast du denn gelernt?
Eine Frage und eine Gegenfrage zu einer ganz schlechter Stilart. Und sag doch erstmal, ob dich das zufriedenstellt, was die anderen gelernt haben. Dann bewahrt ihr euch gerne auch diese Frage.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also diese pessimistische Haltung, die wir hier mal an den Tag tragen und die Paranoia, die ist sicherlich nicht unbegründet. Aber wenn ich nach draußen gucke, dann hat sich so viel getan die letzten 20 Jahre. Das ist großartig.
Okay. Und auch hier die Frage, ist das noch nötig sozusagen weiterhin das zu machen?
Ja, das hört ja nicht auf. Gesellschaft ist ja nie statisch, Technik ist nie statisch. Wir machen bestimmt auch noch, also Andi hat mal auf einem der ersten Kongresse, auf denen ich war, gesagt, alle Veranstaltungen beginnen mindestens eine Stunde später als angekündigt, aber der Club wird länger leben als die Republik. Und ich war von dieser Aussage einfach so dermaßen geflasht und dachte mir, wovon faselt der Kerl denn da? Aber so im Nachgang würde ich sagen, klar, machen wir auch noch die Sendung 423.
Da bin ich sehr gespannt. Chaosradio live, ob du zufrieden bist mit dem, was bis jetzt aus dem Chaosradio sozusagen rausgekommen ist? Und was auch die Moderatoren, die ja sozusagen jetzt am meisten Zeit in den Berliner verbringen mussten.
Ich finde das auf jeden Fall total toll. Also ich finde, ich habe auch, ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele Sendungen ich überhaupt mitgemacht habe, aber ich fand jeder einzelne auf jeden Fall ein Gewinn für alle, auch für mich als Mitquatscher.
Okay, aber bevor du dich jetzt hier aus der Gegenfrage schaffst.
Was für mich tatsächlich das spannendste war, ist, wenn man dem Club auf so eine Art und Weise näher kommen kann, da ist Moderat natürlich eine sehr privilegierte Position, weil man einfach sozusagen eine klare Aufgabe hat und sich trotzdem sehr genau das angucken kann, was da passiert, dann lernt man, dass das auch Leute sind, die mit Wasser kochen. Und das ist sehr beruhigend, weil ich finde, dass der Club von außen schon so eine Ausstrahlung manchmal hat, die sehr ehrfurchtgebietend oder arrogant wirken kann, also uneindringbar. Was Jakob vorhin auch meinte, also die hohe Mauer mit dem Graben davor, so und dahinter ist dann irgendwo der Club, diese Eindrucken steht schon manchmal. Wenn man sozusagen einfach eine Weile dabei ist, dann lernt man, okay, das sind halt Leute, das ist schon mal gut, es gibt keine Clubmeinung und man kann natürlich auch hingehen und was fragen und das fand ich sehr, sehr, sehr lehrreich. Das finde ich jedes Mal lehrreich, wenn man in irgendwas Großes reinkommt, wo es dann herauszieht, okay, das sind Menschen. Verrückt, wer hätte das gedacht, das ist dann irgendwie so eine Binsenwahrheit, aber das lernt man auch da auch hier im Chaosradio und das finde ich halt sehr, sehr, sehr gut.
Da muss ich gleich mal widersprechen. Wir kochen natürlich nicht nur mit Wasser, wir kochen auch mit Termit, wenn es sein muss. Also wir legen uns da jetzt nicht so fest. Und wir haben schon auch Zauberer im Club, die man erst Jahre später versteht, was sie eigentlich gerade sagen wollten. Und es ist auch wichtig, dass man solchen Leuten Forum bietet und ich habe mich auch immer gefreut, dass Fritz das sich getraut hat. Weil das ist ja durchaus für so eine Radiostation ein Risiko. Das hätte ja voll nach hinten losgehen können. Und was uns glaube ich so ein bisschen gerettet hat, ist, dass immer die Messung ein bisschen schwierig ist, wie viel höher man jetzt eigentlich konkret hat gerade. Aber also ich kann mich da nur wiederholen, ich habe zumindest in den Anfangsjahren immer das Gefühl gehabt, so das war jetzt die letzte Sendung, jetzt gehst du hier nochmal hin, nimmst es nochmal mit. Ja und wenn es sich abzeichnet, das geht immer weiter, dann kann es auch immer anders machen.
Mir ging es eins zu eins genauso und offensichtlich auch den Moderatoren, denn eine der beliebtesten Fragen, die in den ersten Folgen aufkam, war nicht, haben wir noch Anrufer, sondern haben wir noch Hörer.
Es scheint noch welche zu geben in der Tat.
Und man darf halt auch nicht vergessen, auf welchem Platz wir damals waren, das war immer Mittwochs von 22 bis 1 Uhr und wir waren eingeklemmt zwischen Paul van Dyck mit irgendwie komischen Techno DJs in Platin Blond, die irgendwie so Stampfmusik spielten.
Quasi auch elektronische Technik.
Ist auch elektronische Technik, Stiefel, Monoton. Genau.
Fühlst du dich jetzt nach den Stahlgitarren besser?
Ja, es gab Stahlgitarren, wo ich kann mich noch an die Chaosradio Sendung erinnern, wo ich Musik mitbringen durfte, da gab es häufiger. Da warst du noch gar nicht da.
Das probieren wir genau einmal.
Das war häufiger, ich hab ein paar Mal Musik mitgebracht.
Jetzt ist der Chaos Computer Club nicht ein Ort, wo man hingehen kann zu diskutieren. Es ist auch nicht so, dass wir diese Wissen in die Welt in eine Radiosendung tragen. Sondern er bietet den betriebtechnischen Infrastruktur. Der Club macht ja auch Internet, wenn man das so sagen will. Was genau passiert da? Was gibt es da alles und warum wird das gemacht?
Was ich vorhin kurz skizziert hatte, wir haben immer versucht zu sagen, wo befinden wir uns in diesem gesellschaftlichen Spannungsfeld? Und was ist die Bedeutung dieser Hochtechnologie? Aus der politischen Linken war das ja eine lange Auseinandersetzung, zum Beispiel mit Atomkraft, um zu verstehen, was passiert denn da, um diese Technik kritisieren zu können. Vor dem Hintergrund willst du dir natürlich RFID auch erstmal angucken, bevor du es verdammst, um nicht so ein pauschalisiertes das ist alles böse und wir wollen es nicht. Der CCC hat in den frühen 80ern die Grünen im Deutschen Bundestag beraten zur Einführung von Computern und die hatten eine klare vorgefertigte Meinung, die sie gerne bestätigt sehen wollten, dass Computern böse sind, das Teufelswerkzeug von 1984 in der Großstaat. Ja, blöd jetzt. Und wenn du dir diese Techniken anguckst, stellst du fest, Technik an und für sich ist zwar nie im eigentlichen Sinne policy-neutral, aber die Art und Weise der Policy hängt davon ab, wer sie definiert. Und diese Kontrolle zu erlangen, diese Wirkmächtigkeit über diese Regelsätze zu erlangen, funktioniert in der Regel nur, indem du die Technik selber betreibst. Wenn du das an dritte Auslage hast, bist du auf Gedeih und Verderb auf deren Implementierung dieser Richtlinien und Regelsätze angewiesen. Was jetzt dank Snowden ganz viele Leute festgestellt haben, dass es eine blöde Idee ist, die Mail bei Google zu halten, weil dann liest Google die Mail halt mit, zwar automatisiert, aber sie lesen sie ständig mit. Und um dem zu entgehen und auch vor dem Hintergrund, dass Infrastruktur damals einfach nicht verfügbar war, dass neue Technologien kamen und niemand einen Streaming-Server betrieben hätte für dich. Du hättest nicht zu einem Anbieter gehen können und sagen können, bau mir doch mal einen Web-Server und einen Streaming-Dienst, weil es diese Angebote schlichtweg nicht gab. Da waren wir eigentlich von Anfang an immer drauf aus und auch dazu verdammt, diese Technik selber zu betreiben. Und natürlich hat es auch so ein emanzipatorisches Moment zu sagen, ich betreibe meine Infrastruktur selber, ich halte die Kontrolle darüber.
Also ihr betreibt jetzt also E-Mail-Server, Jabber-Server, verschiedene Web-Server und diese ganzen Sachen. Und was sich da abzeichnet ist ja, wir haben ja gehört, in Architektik ist Dezentralisierung eigentlich sozusagen so ein Gebot. Das heißt eigentlich, also im extrem theoretischen Idealfall, sollte das jeder für sich selber machen. Jetzt macht der Club das und der Club ist natürlich auch so ein wow, der Club macht das, dann kann ich auch das benutzen. Werdet ihr dann nicht irgendwann einfach zu einer weiteren Instanz die Technik anbieten, der man blind vertraut? Also ist das tatsächlich emanzipatorisch?
Da kämpfen wir auf allen Fronten gegen, denn es gibt auch, es gibt ja gute Argumente dagegen, so was nicht den Club zu geben, selbst wenn der Club das komplette Vertrauen genießt. Denn wir haben die gesetzliche Situation, wenn du einen E-Mail Server betreibst oder ein Internet Provider bist, dass von der Anzahl deiner User abhängt, ob du eine Abhörschnittstelle anbieten musst oder nicht den sogenannten Bedarfsträgern, also der Polizei. Das heißt, wenn der Club jetzt so was betreibt, wie sagen wir einen Jabber Server oder einen E-Mail Server, dann ist das zwar nett, den benutzen zu können und wahrscheinlich vertrauenswürdiger als so die anderen, die es da halt freigibt, aber es ist immer noch besser, selbst einzubetreiben und nicht nur aus Dezentralisierungs- und dogmatischen Gründen, sondern aus handfesten juristischen Gründen und natürlich, weil man dabei was lernt. Rückblicken muss man sagen, das hat uns sehr geholfen, dieser Ansatz, dass wir erst mal selber bauen und daraus dann lernen, wie schlimm irgendwas ist, weil inzwischen ist diese Expertise ja auch gefragt. Also wir sind Gutachter vom Bundesverfassungsgericht gewesen, das ist ja nicht von ungefähr gekommen, sondern weil wir eben diesen Anspruch immer gehabt haben, auch vorher, dass wir das gerne alles verstehen möchten, bevor wir dagegen sind, oder dafür, und häufiger dagegen. Das muss man vielleicht einräumen an der Stelle.
Das soll ab und zu passiert sein.
Ja, aber das ist ein Modell, das funktioniert und das kann ich auch nur allen empfehlen, einfach Sachen selber mal aufzubauen, um zu sehen, wie das denn jetzt eigentlich zusammenspielt. Das ist ein Erfolgserlebnis, was man anders kaum kriegen kann. Selbst irgendwie einen Server gebaut zu haben und den können dann Leute benutzen. Das ist total geil.
Und am Ende stehst du selber da und versuchst die Leute zu motivieren, sich vielleicht doch auch noch mal einen Account bei einem anderen Java-Server zu organisieren, weil sich das mittlerweile alles viel zu sehr auf den CCC betriebenen Server konzentriert. Das ist auch negativ.
Das ist ein echtes Problem. Wir sehen es auch durchaus nicht nur positiv. Also es kam jetzt zum Beispiel bei Wikileaks raus, dass die unseren Java-Server benutzt haben und den dann auch weiter empfohlen haben. Und wenn sowas einmal in der Presse steht, dann kann man sich ja überlegen, ob die Polizei dazusieht oder ob die auch versuchen, eine Leitung hinzulegen. Und das sehen wir nicht nur positiv, wenn die gesamte Republik und alle Dissidenten über unsere Java-Server gehen, sondern das ist schon, Leute macht eure eigenen Java-Server und lernt, wie das funktioniert. Dann ist das Wissen, das werdet ihr irgendwann brauchen.
Jetzt sind wir hier an dem Punkt, wo möglicherweise jemand draußen sitzt und diese Sendung hat, sich da irgendwie zu mahnen. Das wäre eigentlich gar nicht so doof, das vielleicht wirklich mal auszuprobieren. Dann guckt irgendwie im Internet, findet irgendwie vielleicht eine Hilfeanleitung und das funktioniert natürlich nicht genauso, weil Hilfeanleitungen nie genau den Fall beschreiben, den man selber gerade machen will. Ist das dann so ein Punkt, wo man sagen kann, okay jetzt geh ich mal zum Club und frag, ob mir vielleicht jemand hilft? Oder ist das dann sozusagen, ist das zu einfach?
Nee, also genau dafür gibt es Hackerspaces, damit du da reinlaufen kannst mit deinem technischen Problem und dabei was lernen kannst. Oder wenn noch jemand anders da ist, der irgendwas noch weniger verstanden hat, was du verstanden hast, dass du anderen hilfst. Also das ist genau der Grund, warum wir ein Hackerspace haben in Berlin und anderswo.
Aber das ist natürlich auch ein emanzipatorisches Moment und darum ging es auch immer in dieser Situation zu sagen, wir befähigen uns selbst Diskussionen zu dem Thema zu führen und dort Wissen zu verbreiten. Und die Intensität und die Tiefe, hatte ich ja vorhin auch kurz erwähnt, unterscheidet sich dann eben vom Medium. Denn die Anleitung auf einer Website ist eine andere, als du erzählst es in einem Podcast, als du erzählst es auf einer Konferenz, als du erzählst es in einem UKW-Sender für normale Leute. Oder halt auch sagen, eins zu eins in sowas wie dem Chaos Computer Club. Genau, aber das Problem ist die Bequemlichkeit, aber die ist immer unser Feind. Dass man grundsätzlich erstmal faul ist, die Welt ist furchtbar komplex, wie kann ich Komplexität reduzieren und wie kann ich mir Zeit ersparen? Und wenn ich es irgendwie outsourcing kann und sagen kann, jemand anderes macht das für mich, dann habe ich ein Problem los. Nur muss ich mir zunächst mal bewusst werden, was für andere Probleme ich mir damit einhandle. Hatten wir gerade schon erwähnt. Ich muss mir bewusst werden, was für Aufwände erzeugt ist, wenn ich selber mache und welche Vorteile habe ich davon. Und das ist das gleiche, ob ich jetzt irgendwie sage, ich kann ja mein Banking von irgendeinem ausländischen Großkonzern machen lassen oder ich gründe halt eine Genossenschaftsbank oder werde da Mitglied. Oder ich mache einen lokalen Bio-Bauernhof und ziehe mir mein Gemüse selber im Garten. Natürlich machst du das nicht alles selber. Und Brot backen machst du auch nur irgendwie mal so als Lektion. Ist schön, dass du es gelernt hast, aber es nervt, wenn du das jeden Morgen machen musst, bevor du ins Büro gehst. Und funktional ausdifferenzierte Gesellschaften funktionieren so. Aber du musst halt verstehen, was sind deine Kosten? Was sind die Probleme, die du dir ins Haus holst, wenn du nicht drüber nachdenkst?
Und das kann man hier auch lernen.
Das kann man natürlich hier lernen, klar.
Nicht alles zu jedem Zeitpunkt sollten wir gleich dazu sagen. Das ist auch Glückssache, wer gerade hier ist. Und es kann sein, dass jemand mit seinem Problem herkommt und es ist gerade niemand in den Örtlichkeiten, der genau diese Probleme lösen kann. Aber das heißt ja nicht, dass sich der Besuch nicht trotzdem lohnen kann.
Und darüber hinaus haben wir eine Jahresendveranstaltung, auf der sind 10.000 spannende Menschen. Und die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass da jemand, was zu deinem Thema weiß, ist relativ hoch.
Okay, ja, seht ihr eigentlich, also der Club ist ja sozusagen eine Vereinigung von Leuten, die irgendwie technische Dinge machen. Die ist auch immer alles erklärnd, wenn man sie fragt und die mittlerweile auch von großen Gerichten befragt werden. Aber seht ihr eine Aufgabe, die man als Clubmitglied hat? Oder die ihr als mehr oder weniger exponierte Mitglieder des Chaos Computer Clubs habt?
Na erstmal ist es eine Vereinigung, die auf gegenseitigem Vorteil basiert. Also du gehst nicht nur hin, weil du dann Aufgaben hast, anderen Leuten gegenüber, sondern am Ende soll jeder einen Gewinn davon haben, dass er im Club ist. Du erklärst anderen Leuten was und andere Leute erklären dir was. Allerdings wird natürlich schon erwartet, dass wenn jemand eine Frage hat und du kannst sie beantworten, dass du es dann auch tust.
Ich meine, der Club hat ja mittlerweile in der Auswirkung eine Position, wo man sagen kann, das ist gewichtig. Erwächst daraus eine gesellschaftliche Verantwortung, wo ihr glaubt, die müsst ihr wahrnehmen? Oder weißt ihr das im Zweifel von euch? Sagt ihr, das geht uns nicht an, dafür bezahlt uns tatsächlich keiner?
Also die hatten wir von Anfang an und das ist ja auch unser Selbstverständnis, aber das beruht auf Freiwilligkeit und das ist das konstitutive Merkmal des Clubs. Wenn du Lust hast, etwas zu tun, dann machst du das und wir haben alle einen gewissen Antrieb dafür sicherzustellen, dass es uns gut geht und unserem erweiterten Umfeld und das funktioniert in der Demokratie halt so, dass du die anderen überzeugen musstest, dass was du als Idee hast, als politische Idee und als Anspruch hast, die richtige Option ist und für das kämpfen wir. Aber natürlich sind wir alle hier freiwillig ehrenamtlich und unbezahlt und das schränkt erheblich unsere Fähigkeiten, einen das zu tun und damit solltest du dir aber auch diese Verantwortung nicht aufbürden, denn sonst gehst du daran kaputt, weil alleine kann man die Welt nicht retten.
Aber das stellt sich natürlich sozusagen die Frage, jetzt gibt es diesen Club, der Club ist nicht wirklich klein, der Club kriegt so eine Großveranstaltung gestemmt, wie im Kongress, wenn ich es richtig verstehe, hohe vierstellige oder kleine fünfstellige Zahl an Leuten da ist. Das ist doch sozusagen zumindest ein Konstrukt, wo man auch ein bisschen Geld hat und sagt, okay, dann stellen wir einfach jetzt jemanden an, der sich um keine Ahnung Pressearbeit kümmert, der diese Server macht. Aber wenn ich es richtig verstehe, ist alles alles ehrenamtlich. Warum? Warum nicht einfach sagen, okay, hier, du machst es jetzt?
Weil das der Charakter des Clubs ist. Du veränderst fundamental deine politische Aufgabe mit Hauptamtlichen. Und das ist das, was wir an allen politischen Organisationen im In- und Ausland sehen. Wenn du Hauptamtliche beschäftigst, haben die ein Eigeninteresse daran, organisationssoziologisch betrachtet, dass der Apparat wächst und stabil bleibt.
Okay, warte, kannst du nochmal erklären, ohne das Wort organisationssoziologisch zu verwenden?
Weil es gibt keine Schere im Kopf.
Weil so hört sich das so ein bisschen an, wie das ist so. Wir machen das so, weil es ist so. Aber warum?
Nein, es gibt wichtige Gründe, aber die können wir jetzt nicht erklären.
Das ist doch Quatsch.
Da müssen wir nicht leider erschießen.
Das kann...
Nein, also das ist eine lange Diskussion.
Also grundsätzlich ist es so, wenn dein Einkommen davon abhängt, dass du, dass dieses Problem da draußen existiert, dann hast du kein Interesse daran, dieses Problem zu lösen.
Ah, aber okay, sagen, das kann man für politische Arbeit sagen, also keine Ahnung, wir kämpfen gegen Vorratsratenspeicherung. Wenn ich dafür bezahlt werde, gegen Vorratsratenspeicherung zu kämpfen, bin ich nicht daran interessiert, dass sie jemals abgeschafft wird, weil dann werde ich nicht mehr bezahlt, dagegen zu kämpfen. Aber der Betrieb einer technischen Infrastruktur könnte doch so eine Aufgabe sein.
Aber es ist doch genauso, wenn ich Geld dafür bekomme, dass Leute mir im Monat, was weiß ich, einen Honi in die Hand drücken, um eine Mailadresse bei mir zu haben, dann habe ich kein Interesse, dass sie das selber lernen.
Ah, nun wird mir einiges klarer.
Das ist wie mit den Grünen und der Atomkraft.
Das musst du jetzt nochmal genauer erklären.
Ja, naja, die Grünen waren ja immer für die Abschaffung der Atomkraftwerke, bis die CDU dann dafür war, dann waren sie plötzlich dagegen. Und das ist genau der Effekt, den wir ganz vermeiden versuchen.
Gut, wir haben jetzt also schon gelernt, was der Chaos Computer Club mit den Atomkraftwerken der Grünen zu tun hat. Ich muss das erstmal noch ein bisschen sacken lassen, ihr vielleicht auch, wir machen deswegen kurz Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr und sind dann gleich wieder für euch da hier im Chaos Radio.
Was gibt's besseres als ein geiles Spiel auf deinem eigenen Sofa, mit deinen besten Freunden und 12.000 anderen Fußballfans alle zusammen in einem Wohnzimmer? Na passt mal auf. Zur Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft verwandelt Fritz zusammen mit euch das Stadion an der Alten Försterei zum größten Wohnzimmer der Welt und von Berlin. Und mit ein bisschen Glück steht euer eigenes Sofa mittendrin. Vier Wochen lang und nur für euch reserviert wird.
Wenn ihr also dabei sein wollt und euer Sofa einverstanden ist, dann klickt doch mal auf fritz.de slash Wohnzimmer.
Das WM Wohnzimmer im Stadion an der Alten Försterei.
Klingt ganz schön abgefahren, wird ganz schön abgefahren, sind wir dabei.
Um 23.29.
UN-Generalsekretär Ban Ki-moon hat vor einer militärischen Eskalation in der Ukraine gewarnt. Diese müsse um jeden Preis vermieden werden. Er sei besorgt, dass die Situation jederzeit außer Kontrolle geraten kann, mit Folgen, die niemand absehen könne. Es herrsche ein Klima der Angst und Furcht in der Ostukraine, sagte Ban. Alle Seiten müssten sich strikt an den in Genf vereinbarten Friedensplan halten. Die ukrainische Armee hat heute während eines Angriffs fünf pro-russische Separatisten erschossen. Russland reagierte mit einem Militärmanöver an der ukrainischen Grenze. Die Armutsquote in Deutschland hat nach Ansicht des paritätischen Wohlfahrtverbandes einen Höchststand erreicht. Jeder Sechste müsse mit weniger als 950 Euro im Monat auskommen. Besonders armutsgefährdet seien Erwerbslose und Alleinerziehende, so der Wohlfahrtsverband. Es habe noch nie so viel Privatvermögen in Deutschland gegeben wie heute, aber auch noch nie so viele überschuldete Menschen. Jeder zehnte Erwachsene gelte mittlerweile als überschuldet. Auf dem deutschen Arbeitsmarkt gibt es nach Einschätzung des Paritätischen immer weniger klassische sozialversicherungspflichtige Vollzeitarbeitsplätze. Ein Jahr nach dem Einsturz einer Textilfabrik in Bangladesch haben Gewerkschaften und Hilfsorganisationen weitere Konsequenzen gefordert. Von der Gewerkschaft Verdi hieß es, Modefirmen müssten mehr Verantwortung übernehmen und transparenter arbeiten. Diskutiert wird außerdem über ein neues Textilsiegel, das Kunden beim Kauf von Kleidung mehr Informationen über die Herkunft geben soll. Bei dem Fabrikunglück in Bangladesch vor über einem Jahr kamen rund 1000 Menschen ums Leben. Auch deutsche Modefirmen haben in der Fabrik produzieren lassen. Die deutsche Schullandschaft hat sich in den vergangenen zehn Jahren stark verändert. Es gibt inzwischen ein Drittel weniger Hauptschulen, dafür aber 22 Prozent mehr Waldorfschulen, teilte das Statistische Bundesamt mit. Es gäbe auch rund doppelt so viele integrierte Gesamtschulen wie noch vor zehn Jahren. Deutschlandweit ist die Zahl der allgemein bildenden Schulen um etwa 6000 gesunken. Der Grund ist, es gibt weniger Schüler als früher. Derzeit Temperaturen zwischen 11 und 15 Grad in Berlin und Brandenburg. Die Luft ist überall recht feucht, dunstig sozusagen. Regnen soll es in den kommenden Stunden aber nicht mehr. Wie schon in den vergangenen Tagen startet der Morgen in Berlin und Brandenburg fast überall sonnig. Später können dann wieder einige kurze Regenschauer runterkommen. 20 bis 23 Grad sind angesagt. Mit einer Meldung zur Berliner S-Bahn. Bis Betriebsschluss fahren die Regenbahnlinien S41 und S42 zwischen Treptower Park und Südkreuz nur im 20-Minuten-Takt. Die S45 fährt heute Nacht verkürzt, und zwar nur zwischen Schöneweide und Flughafen Schönefeld. Und die S46 fährt nur zwischen Königs-Wusterhausen und Hermannstraße und nicht weiter bis Westend.
Gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBW.
Und wenn ihr bei Fritz mitmachen wollt, dann macht doch mit. Auf fritz.de slash mitmachen.
Eine halbe Stunde haben wir noch hier im Chaos Radio im Blumen, heute live aus der Marienstraße 11 aus dem Chaos Computer Club Berlin. Und wir haben während dieser Sendung, der 200. schon sehr viel darüber gelernt, wie der Chaos Computer Club funktioniert und wie das Chaos Radio funktioniert. Und bei letzterem haben wir auch gelernt, dass es eine große Schwierigkeit ist, die Leute vom Chaos Computer Club so zu bremsen und das so in Form zu bringen, dass man es auch als normaler Mensch versteht, der versucht, dieser Radiosendung zu folgen. Und genau das wollen wir aber jetzt mal probieren. Also ob sich das in den letzten 200 Sendungen tatsächlich so gestaltet hat, dass da ein Lerneffekt eingetreten ist bei den Leuten, die das Chaos Radio häufiger besuchen. Und dazu haben wir jetzt die Nerd News. Das sind sozusagen vier einzelne Meldungen, die wir erst verlesen werden und dann...
Und du erklärst sie dann mit dem in der Sendung gewonnenen Wissen?
Und dann erklärt ihr die, und zwar so, dass es jeder versteht. Wir beginnen jetzt mit den Nerd News und wir heißen herzlich willkommen Nachrichtensprecher Heuer Klein.
Falsche Post vom Amt. Das sogenannte Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik BSI hat vor Fishing-Mails gewarnt. Sie geben vor, vom BSI selbst zu stammen und unterstellen dem Empfänger, Zitat, vermehrte illegale Aktivitäten. Weiter fordern sie zum Herunterladen eines Erklärungsformulars auf. In Wirklichkeit wartet hinter dem Link jedoch sehr wahrscheinlich ein Trojaner. Das BSI rät dringend, entsprechende E-Mails sofort zu löschen.
Warum ist das schlimm? Was ist da los?
Ich finde das gar nicht schlimm. Ich finde das eine tolle Meldung, weil die kam nämlich genau in der Zeit, als wir gesagt haben, wenn ihr hier Trojaner macht als Regierung, dann wird euch keiner mehr glauben, dass die normalen Mails vom Finanzamt vertrauenswürdig sind. Und das war so ein bisschen ein Argument, was in der Luft hing und dann kam diese Geschichte und damit war das auch für den Netzen illustriert, dass nur wenn eine Mail kommt, wo drauf steht, das ist vom BSI oder vom BKA, gab es später auch mal so eine Welle. Das heißt noch lange nicht, dass das nicht eine Mail ist, die deinen Computer kaputt macht, wenn du sie aufmachst.
Aber damit fängt man sofort... Mit D-Mail wäre das nicht... Ja, das wollte ich gerade sagen. Ja, also jetzt doch die E-Mail benutzen, ja?
Um Gottes Willen.
Wieso nicht? Das schützt uns doch davor.
Ja, nee, tut es überhaupt nicht. Wie kommst du denn darauf, dass es uns schützt?
Nee, das wurde doch gesagt, dass es sicher ist.
Ja, ja, das ist...
Ist sicher.
Was sollen die auch sonst sagen? Nein, das wurde nicht gesagt. Das haben die ins Gesetz geschrieben, weil sie es nicht sagen können.
Das ist Open SSL gesichert.
Du hast... THS, vielen Dank. Was ist das?
Open SSL gesichert.
Was bedeutet das denn?
Das ist besonders sicher. Weil es ist Open Source. Sicherheit.
Also, man sieht also... Ich fürchte, ich kann das jetzt tatsächlich nicht in aller Ausführlichkeit erklären, aber ich sage mal, NerdNews 1 gescheitert. Kommen wir zur nächsten Nachricht.
Routine Hintertür nur scheinbar behoben. Eine Reihe von Netgear-Routern ist trotz eines Sicherheitsupdates weiter verwundbar. Schickt ein Angreifer ein spezielles Paket an ein aktualisiertes Modell, so wird die angeblich entfernte Hintertür wieder geöffnet. Sie erlaubt weitreichenden Zugriff auf alle Routerfunktionen. Warum diese offenkundig absichtlich eingebaute Funktion nicht komplett entfernt wurde, überprüft Netgear derzeit. Die Firmware stammt vom Unternehmen ZERCOM, das auch für andere Routerhersteller produziert. Um die Router nach dem Update anzugreifen, muss der Angreifer allerdings im gleichen WLAN sich im gleichen WLAN befinden oder Kunde beim gleichen Provider sein.
Du arbeitest bei einem Routerhersteller als Programmierer. Was ist ein Router? Ein Router ist die kleine Plastebox, die dafür sorgt, dass du zu Hause Internet hast. Die spricht mit deiner Telefonfirma, vielleicht mit der Telekom oder so. Und macht dann, dass bei dir zu Hause alle Geräte Internet haben und auf der anderen Seite spricht es mit deinem Internetanbieter und vermittelt zwischen euch. Ist also aus dem Internet erreichbar. Und was die Programmierer dieses Betriebssystems darauf gemacht haben, ist eine Hintertür einzubauen, mit der sie dann aus dem Internet auf alle Geräte voll zugreifen können. Das war ganz offensichtlich so jetzt nachträglich erst klar geworden, dass es wohl absichtlich war, weil als sie versprochen haben, diese Hintertür zu entfernen, wurden dieselben Funktionen immer noch in dem Betriebssystem gefunden. Allerdings wurden sie so geschützt, dass man vorher an ganz bestimmte Ports geheime Pakete schicken musste, damit diese Funktion wieder angeschaltet wird. Also der Programmierer, der sie ursprünglich reingetragen hatte, hatte kein Interesse daran, seine tolle Hintertür da wieder rauszunehmen.
Das heißt, wer jetzt so einen Router zu Hause stehen hat, der hat ein kleines Überwachungsgerät, das man von außen abfragen kann.
Ich kauf keine Netgear-Hardware mehr.
Okay, also ich glaube, Port und Pakete, das hätte man noch genauer, aber ich vergebe mal einen Punkt. Kommen wir zur nächsten Nachricht.
Indonesischer Provider leitet Internet um. Falsche Routing-Informationen des Internetanbieters Indosat haben Anfang April den weltweiten Internetverkehr gestört. Verantwortlich war vermutlich ein Konfigurationsfehler. Dadurch behaupteten Indosats Router gegenüber anderen Netzanbietern, den Weg zu wichtigen Firmen wie etwa Akamai bereitzustellen. Möglich ist dies durch das Routing-Protokoll BGP. Mit BGP verständigen sich die wichtigsten Router im Internet über die Zustellung von Daten. So können Sie im Falle von Umstrukturierungen oder Leitungsausfällen schnell andere Zustellwege verhandeln. Wer einen solchen Router betreibt, kann allerdings per bloßer Behauptung Internetverkehr umleiten. 2010 war dies dem chinesischen Provider passiert, einem chinesischen Provider passiert, ebenfalls als Folge eines Konfigurationsfehlers.
Erst mal 100 Punkte für Holgi, finde ich. Wenn diese Bewertung so derart professionell vorträgt.
In der Tat, aber THS bitte was?
Ja, genau. Über BGP kann ich wahrscheinlich genauso viel erzählen aber worum geht es hier im Grunde genommen?
Also ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ja, über Internetbequemlichkeitsprotokolle, die mal konzipiert wurden zu Zeiten, da gab es halt noch nicht so viele Feinde. Ich gebe einfach weiter an den BGP-Spezialisten. Da habe ich eben gerade schon daran gedacht.
Das Problem ist ja, du hast ja ein Plastik-Computer.
Grüß dich, Spezialisten Nibbler, hallo, guten Tag.
Ich würde jetzt nicht Spezialist sagen, aber...
Super Spezialexperte?
Spezialexperte. Okay, Spezialexperte.
Was da passiert ist, ist, dass der Router von diesem Netzbetreiber behauptet hat, dass er für bestimmte IP-Adressen zuständig sei, für die er gar nicht zuständig war. Das funktioniert deswegen, weil so Router im Internet sich über das BGP-Protokoll austauschen und dem anderen Router sagen, hallo, die und die IP-Adressen, die kannst du bei mir erreichen. Der sagt dann, ok, weiß ich Bescheid und gibt das weiter an den nächsten Router. Und so kann sich sowas dann im Internet propagieren.
Das Problem ist...
Darf ich kurz fragen?
Na dein Computer zu Hause hat eine IP-Adresse.
Aber die ganzen anderen Computer im Internet müssen ja irgendwo wissen, wo sie das Paket hinschicken sollen. Die schicken das erstmal zu ihrem Provider. Da stehen dann weitere Router und die wissen Bescheid, wo welche Internet-IP im Internet zu Hause ist.
Und das wissen sie, weil sie miteinander BGP sprechen.
Das ist aber nicht das, was ich eben vorgelesen habe.
Doch, doch, doch. Na ja, doch, doch, doch, doch. Das steht da nicht. Das Problem ist jetzt, wenn jetzt irgendeiner dieser Router da draußen im Internet behauptet, hallo, ich hab hier die IP-Adresse vom Holgi, dann schicken die halt Pakete, die an die IP-Adresse vom Holgi gehen, an diesen Router.
Man kann zwar verifizieren, ob das stimmt, aber das funktioniert nicht im ganzen Internet. Viel ist da durch Vertrauen, gerade zwischen großen Providern. Wenn zwischen zwei großen Providern sowas passiert, dann ist die Tendenz im Internet trotzdem noch, dass man dem großen Provider glaubt, weil die würden ja nicht irgendwelche falschen Routen schicken. Da gibt es inzwischen Mechanismen, aber das ist weltweit noch nicht so richtig.
Im Prinzip könnte ich sagen, hey hallo, ich bin eine Sparkasse.
Genau. Cool, gib mir dein Geld. Das Lustige ist, du kannst die Pakete von der Sparkasse auch zu der Sparkasse weiter schicken, wenn du einen sehr kurzen Fahrt zu der Sparkasse hast. Das kannst du meinetwegen den ganzen Tag machen, das fällt keinem so richtig doll schnell aus.
Kann man schon mit dem Ding überwachen?
Nee, es geht nicht nur überwachen. Also pass auf, ich gebe dir ein Paket an dich. Gibt es meiner Post? Und meine Post hat eine Tabelle und weiß, Pakete an denen gehen hier lang. So gehen über Hamburg, weiß ich. Das ist eine Route, sowas gibt es auch im Internet. Was jetzt passiert ist, ist, dass ein Paket an Holgi nicht direkt über diese Route geht, sondern da fragt man erstmal, weiß jemand, wo geht es zu Holgi? Über einen Protokoll, also man redet miteinander und da kam ja die Telekom Singapore. Du fragst mich, wo muss das hin?
Hört ihr die Musik?
Im Wesentlichen kommt die Telekom Singapore und sagt, ich weiß, wo es zu Holgi geht, und zwar bei mir.
Also ich muss an dieser Stelle keinen Punkt vergeben. Aber wir haben ja noch eine Nachricht, vielleicht kommt es noch zu einem Ausgleich.
TrueCrypt nimmt nächste Hürde. Nach den NSA-Enthüllungen von Edward Snowden hat das Open Crypto Audit Project den Code des Verschlüsselungsprogramms TrueCrypt untersuchen lassen. Ein entsprechender Prüfbericht liegt nun vor. Mithilfe von Spendengeldern sollen nun eine formale Krypto-Analyse sowie ein Bug-Bounty-Programm sicherstellen, dass das Open Source-Programm keine Hintertüren enthält. Außerdem sollen Probleme im Zusammenhang mit der Lizenz von TrueCrypt ausgeräumt. Das Open Crypto-Audit Project wurde von international bekannten Kryptografen gegründet, darunter dem Security-Autor Bruce Schneier.
Vielen Dank. Nachrichtsprecher Holger Klein. Einen Applaus bitte. Aber trotzdem möchte ich an dieser Stelle Arthur fragen, Entschuldigung, wie?
Ja, ich versuch das mal auf zwei Ebenen. Das eine ist die Ebene, was dieses Programm tut. Dieses Programm verschlüsselt Festplatten und andere Speichermedien, sodass, wenn dieses Speichermedium verloren geht oder eine dritte Person drauf Zugriff hat, diese Person ohne den Kenntnis eines Schlüssels die Inhalte nicht auslesen kann. Wenn du also deine Urlaubsfotos auf einem USB-Stick speicherst, um sie deiner Mutter zu schicken und der geht unterwegs in der Post verloren, dann sieht jeder deine Urlaubsfotos. Wenn du sie verschlüsselst, kann sie nur jemand sehen, der Kenntnis von diesem Schlüssel hat. Das ist zumindest das, was das Programm tun soll. Bei einem Programm gibt es also einen Menschen, der sagt, das ist eine Zielsetzung. Und dann muss ein anderer Mensch, wir nennen ihn Programmierer, versuchen diese Anweisungen, Anweisungen für die Maschine umzusetzen, indem er sie programmiert. Und das macht er nicht in einer Menschensprache, sondern in einer Computersprache. Das heißt, er macht eine Übersetzungsleistung zwischen dieser menschlichen Sprache. Da darf kein anderer darauf zugreifen. Mach mal den folgenden Funktionsaufruf. Bei einer Software, die nicht open source ist, hast du keine Möglichkeit nachzuvollziehen, ob das Programm das tut, was behauptet, dass es tut. Geschweige denn kannst du nachvollziehen, ob es nicht auch noch andere Dinge tut. Sehr viel schwerer ist es negativ, um zu beweisen. Das kannst du allerdings tun, wenn du den Quellcode dazu hast, wenn du diese Maschinenanweisungen hast, in einer Computersprache, in der steht Tue das Folgende, kannst du prüfen, ob das Programm tatsächlich das Folgende tut.
Sehe OpenSSL.
Seht darum Censio OpenSSL, esche die Länder!
Ich möchte an dieser Stelle kurz unterbrechen, die Erklärung von Arthur, die ich bis jetzt sehr gelungen fand, und möchte schon mal ankündigen, Chaosradio 201, Thema OpenSSL, Gast THS. Doch, doch, doch, so wird es kommen. So Arthur, bitte weiter, fahre fort.
Fahre fort, fahre er fort, aber nicht überlos. Um das zu verifizieren, brauchst du aber eine andere Person, die qualifiziert ist, diese Sprache zu verstehen. Also wieder ein Übersetzer, diesmal aus der Maschinensprache zurück in die menschliche Anweisung. Das heißt, ein weiterer Programmierer oder mehrere lesen dann diesen Quelltext, den sie im Fall von sogenannten Open Source offenen Quellen einsehen können und versuchen herauszufinden, was dieses Programm alles macht und ob die Anweisungen, die dieses Programm der Maschine gibt, die sind, die die ursprünglichen Menschen sich ausgedacht haben, dass es das tun soll. Also es ist eine Prüfung, macht das Programm das, was es vorgibt zu tun und macht es nur das, was es vorgibt zu tun. Und Klassenkontrolle für die Software? Genau, und das nennt man Audit aus dem englischen Auditieren. Also es ist eine Prüfung, ob das Programm tatsächlich das tut. Also eine Rückübersetzung, wo ein zweiter Programmierer prüft, ob der erste Programmierer seine Aufgabe richtig gemacht hat. Dieser fremdsprachemächtiger Mensch prüft, ob der andere Mensch dieser fremdsprachemächtige ist.
Bonusfrage, was ist ein Bug Bounty Programm?
Eben funktional ausdifferenzierten kapitalistischen Gesellschaften. Gibt es intrinsische Anreize? Die Anreize im Chaos Computer Club sind so, ich finde das toll, ich will das haben. Und das ermüdet irgendwann. Irgendwann denkst du, ich hätte jetzt gerne mal einen Schnitzel. Oder ich würde gerne mal eine Woche Urlaub machen. Und dafür musst du diese kleinen kapitalistischen Währungseinheiten auf den Tisch legen, weil hier alles mit Geld geregelt wird. Da haben wir ja Andi. Warum sollen die jungen Andelen dafür Geld geben, dass sie das Lied ihre Eltern singen dürfen? Weswegen gibt es zwei Modelle. Eine Modell ist eine Lizenz. Das kommt dann gleich weiter unten. Ich nehme es schon mal vorweg. Wenn ich ein Programm schreibe, habe ich ein Werk geschaffen, wie ein Autor, der ein Buch schreibt und eine Geschichte erzählt.
Ich geh mal kurz ein Bier holen.
Ich wollte gerade sagen. Also im Ansatz sehr gut, aber zu lang.
Okay, ich kürze es jetzt auf die letzten 30 Sekunden runter. Dann haben wir glaube ich keinen Hörer mehr. Du schreibst eine Geschichte. Und diese Geschichte darf von allen anderen verbreitet, verändert, genutzt werden, weil diese Geschichte unter einer offenen Lizenz steht. Und der Vorteil an dieser Software ist, jeder kann Veränderungen einbringen, aber es können nur qualifizierte Personen tun. Und um solche Fehler zu finden, um solche Audits zu tun, musst du einen Preis ausloben. Und ein Bug Bounty Programm ist die Auslobung eines Preises für jemanden, der sich diese Geschichte von vorne bis hinten liest und sagt, das ist ein Kommafehler. Also ich red dir für das Lektorat.
Ich glaube, dieser Satz hätte gereicht. Tatsächlich. Danke, danke Arthorz. Auch ein Beifall für Arthorz.
Ich finde, Arthorz sollte auf jeden Fall sehr viel häufiger Chaosradio machen.
Ja, also ich vergebe mal zwei von vier Punkten. Das ist schon nicht schlecht. Und man könnte vielleicht denken, 200 Sendungen, das ist schon puh. Aber gut, es gibt ja vielleicht nochmal schon. Die Frage ist, was wird denn jetzt eigentlich aus dem Chaosradio in Zukunft? Und ich habe das auch die alten Moderatoren gefragt, also Johnny Häusler, Max von Malodki, Jakob Kranz und Holger Klein. Und die haben dazu Folgendes gesagt.
Ich wünsche mir, dass die weiter so avantgarde sind in Sachen Themen.
Ich wünsche mir das, was ich mir von allen klugen Menschen wünsche, nämlich Aufklärung und Debatte, Kommunikation, das Reden darüber, wie sich unser Leben, unsere Gesellschaft entwickelt und verändert. Ich glaube, das tut das Chaosradio sehr, sehr gut. Es ist natürlich eine Sendung für Menschen, die sich prinzipiell für das dahinter interessieren, also die nicht nur oberflächliches Wissen vermittelt bekommen wollen. Und davon gibt es ja zum Glück genug Menschen, die das so haben wollen. Und ich erwarte mir, deswegen kommt vom Chaosradio nach wie vor, dass es versucht aufzuklären, zu informieren, zu debattieren und auch eine gute Zeit zu haben mit diesem ganzen Technikkram da draußen, mit dem wir irgendwie umgehen müssen. Jetzt nochmal ganz anders, wo wir wissen, dass wir einerseits was ganz Großartiges da vor uns haben und andererseits aber auch eine Maschinerie, die es halt möglich macht, uns alle, die ganze Welt draußen in irgendeiner Form zu kontrollieren und zu überwachen. Und wie das jetzt weitergeht, liegt glaube ich in unser allen Händen.
Dass es mindestens 400 gibt. Nein, es muss natürlich 666 geben. Nein, es muss natürlich... Also ich würde mir wünschen, dass das Chaosradio weiterhin überraschend bleibt, weiterhin auch von Seiten des CCC immer wieder auf Leuten auf die Füße tritt und sagt so nicht. Und wenn es nur der ganz kleine Satz ist, von wegen macht bitte eure Backups auf dem Telefon. Weil man kann in einer Welt, die so digital vernetzt ist wie die unsere, und das ist wahrscheinlich nur der Anfang, wenn wir in 2000 Jahren mal in die Geschichtsbücher gucken, werden die noch lachen, weil die hatten Telefone da, das ist ja lustig. Ich finde, man kann auch ganz viel für seinen Alltag dazulernen. Und man muss auch als Normalsterblicher, zum letzten Mal dieses Wort gebraucht, ein bisschen die Scheuklappen ablegen und sagen, ja, das sind eben keine Nerds. Das sind einfach Typen, die sich mit Dingen beschäftigen, die mein Leben auch betreffen. Und ich bin ganz froh, dass die sich damit beschäftigen, da muss ich nämlich nicht machen. Aber es wäre schön, wenn die mir das so erklären, dass ich es verstehe.
Ich wünsche mir vom Chaosradio, dass es nicht aufhört.
Einer machen wir noch. Tatsächlich scheint das bei den Moderatoren ganz gut angekommen zu sein. Und das klingt so ein bisschen so, mach das weiter so.
Ein Moderator fehlt ja noch.
Was ist das, dass ihr immer so drauf rumreiten müsst? Du bist unser Moderator, sagt denn Herr Richter eigentlich. Aber an dieser Stelle kann ich nicht antworten. Weil ihr habt ja vorhin ganz selber ganz gut erklärt, dass man in gewissen Jobs hat man ja einfach sozusagen per se kein Interesse daran, dass die aufhören, weil, naja, es sind total geile Jobs. So sieht es aus. Ich will natürlich, dass es immer weiter geht, aber das zählt überhaupt gar nicht, wie ihr selber ausführlich in der Sendung erklärt habt.
Wer war das nochmal?
Er erklärt es. Was wünscht ihr euch denn von Chaosradio in Zukunft?
Ich würde mir wünschen, dass es weiter stattfindet, dass Fritz uns diese Gelegenheit weitergibt. Herzlichen Dank an dieser Stelle. Und ich würde mir auf jeden Fall wünschen, dass es da draußen genügend interessierte Personen als Hörer gibt, die uns immer wieder zeigen, dass es sich lohnt, das zu tun und die die Diskussion am Laufen halten und die sich für ihre gesellschaftspolitischen Themen interessieren und für die Welt, in der sie leben. Und ich wünsche mir, dass es weiterhin Spaß macht, denn es ist immer auch ein Faktor, das Ding hat einfach ihre Spaß gemacht, sonst wären wir da nicht rausgefahren.
Sehr gut. FIFA hat ja eigentlich schon gesagt, Radio ist eh doof und so, aber hast du noch Erwartungen ans Chaosradio?
Ja klar, also Chaosradio hat, wir haben schon aufgezählt, was es alles erreicht hat über die Jahre. Und ich sehe keinen Grund, warum es aufhören sollte, damit Dinge zu erreichen. Man muss es natürlich weitermachen, klar. Was ich mir wünschen würde, ist, dass wir es in höherem Maße als bisher schaffen, ein bisschen Variationen in die CCC-Leute zu schicken, die wir da hinschicken. Weil das ist immer die Gefahr, wenn man sowas macht und sich das über 20 Jahre eintritt, dass es dann so eine Echo-Kammer wieder wird. Das ist genau das Gegenteil dessen, was wir erreichen wollen. Wir möchten eine offene Debatte haben. Das ist natürlich gut, wenn Leute anrufen und da Varianz einbringen. Aber es ist auch wichtig, dass wir frisches Blut kriegen. Das wäre einer meiner Wünsche, dass wir es noch mehr schaffen, nicht nur dieselben Leute immer hinzuschicken.
Liebe Chaos Computer Club Leute aus Berlin und Brandenburg, kommt vorbei, macht mit.
Ich war erst plötzlich wieder da.
THS mal abgesehen davon, dass wir dich in der nächsten Sendung begrüßen. Worauf ich mich schon sehr freue. Was wünscht ihr noch vom Chaos Radio?
Ich bin da glaube ich gar nicht in Deutschland.
Dafür werden wir schon sorgen, mit den Füßen am Boden festgenagelt.
Aber egal.
Ansonsten vom Chaos Radio?
Wie gesagt, ich habe meine erste Sendung ungefähr vor 13 Jahren gemacht zusammen mit Erdgeist und ich hatte den Eindruck, da gab es ein paar mehr Anrufer. Also Leute, die halt wirklich auch gefragt haben, Sachen gefragt haben und sich für die Themen interessiert haben und da diskutieren wollten. Das ist heute nicht mehr so. Das finde ich eigentlich ein bisschen blöd. Ich wünschte mir, das wäre ein bisschen, so würde wir so ein bisschen in die Richtung gehen, dass Leute auch anrufen.
Okay, also falls ihr das nächste Mal Chaosradio hört und wir nicht direkt zu Viermillion unterwegs sind, dann könnt ihr gerne anrufen. Die Nummer ist, könnt ihr euch jetzt schon mal aufschreiben, 0331 77 97 110. Wenn man es gelernt hat, hat man es gelernt. Dann kommt es auch gleich mal ansagen.
Erdgeist, Chaosradio und du.
Ich würde mir wünschen, dass es genau den Impact hat, den ich da gerade aus Bernau gelesen habe, das hier im Sendegebiet und im Chat wurde mir gerade mitgeteilt, dass der Chaos-Traff Bernau sich genau zusammengefunden hat, weil sie alle Chaosradio gehört haben und in der Meinung waren, zu Zeiten, als es mit den Foren noch nicht so richtig gang und gäbe war, dass man sozusagen Nischeninteresse dort gleichgesinnte gefunden hat, hat man Chaosradio gehört und gesagt, da sind Nerds, da sind Nerds wie ich, und die kann man treffen und anfassen. Dieser Treffen in Bernau hat sich dort so konstituiert und so sind die Leute zusammengefunden. Dieses positive Erlebnis würde ich mir auch immer wieder, dieses Feedback würde ich mir wünschen, von noch mehr Leuten hören zu können. Und deswegen gehen wir auch mal wieder über UKW nach ganz Brandenburg raus.
Und sogar übers Internet in die ganze Welt. Aber du hast mal was gesagt, dass das mit der Themensuche über die Jahre schwieriger wurde, weil früher gab es mehr niedrig hängendere Früchte. Wie hat sich das verändert und wie wird sich das weiter verändern?
Na es war natürlich, wenn man sich so anguckt in den Jahren, dass dort Sendungen über Wi-Fi gab, über Microsoft, wo Google der große heiße Scheiß gewesen ist, der da gerade jetzt kommt, war das natürlich, damals konnte man mit dem, was man sich dort im Club da so zugeworfen hatte, mit den spannenden Bits ins Radio gehen und war dann irgendwie noch der Oberchecker. Inzwischen ist es im Vergleich zu damals, wo, wenn man was mit Computern macht, war das was Besonderes. Heutzutage ist man, wenn man nichts mit Computern macht, was Besonderes. So dass es deutlich schwieriger ist, einfach nur irgendwelche Anekdoten fallen zu lassen, so eine ganze Sendung zu bestreiten, wo man noch ernsthaft Wissen vermittelte. Da hat man, oder ich zumindest, jetzt doch noch Anspruch, mich intensiver vorzubereiten, bevor ich da reingehe. Und ich hab irgendwie bis heute noch jedes Mal einen fiesen Lampenfieber, bevor ich mich in die Sendung reinsetze. Weil ich denke, irgendwann kriegen sie raus, dass wir hier einfach nur alles Hochstapler sind. Und dann tragen sie uns raus.
Ich denke, das wird bis auf weiteres nicht passieren. Kannst du ein Thema sagen, wo du glaubst, das wird in näherer Zukunft mal Chaosradio eine Rolle spielen? Also außer Open SSL, weil das macht THS ja nächstes Mal?
Ich bin gar nicht da, glaube ich.
Nein.
Ok, Arthur, hast du was, wo du sagst, ok, das ist wahrscheinlich ein Thema, was uns die nächste Zeit bewegen wird?
Mir fallen so unglaublich viele Sachen ein, die demnächst passieren werden. Ich kann da kein Einzelnes rausholen. Und leider ist meine Kristallkugel gerade schmutzig. Ich weiß nicht, was uns als nächstes auf die Füße fällt.
Aha, hast du ein Verdacht? Okay, wir müssen jetzt noch mal ganz zum Schluss, wir müssen wirklich gleich Schluss machen. Aber ihr habt jetzt eine Minute Zeit, um nochmal eure Fähigkeiten beizustellen und zu erklären, warum dieses Thema Open SSL in dieser Sendung der Insider war, die man nicht erklären konnte, weil es zu kompliziert ist. Aber was ist mit diesem Thema los, warum ist es so wichtig und warum werden wir in der nächsten Sendung drüber reden?
Die Erde ist voll überwacht, alle elektronische Kommunikation wird abgefangen und vermutlich für immer gespeichert. Das einzige Mittel, was wir aus den Snowden Enthüllungen gelernt haben, ist starke Verschlüsselung, Kryptographie. In der Open-Source-Welt hat man sich darauf geeinigt, dass man die Anstrengungen, die ja unbezahlt sind, bündelt. Und deswegen gibt es eine einzige, weitverbreitete Bibliothek, die das tut und die heißt OpenSSL. Und die ist so was von verrottet und stinkt zum Himmel.
Und das weiß keiner und das ist das Problem.
Na jetzt weiß es schon jemand.
Es gibt immer noch Leute, die wissen das immer noch nicht.
Und deswegen werden wir in der nächsten Chaosradio senden.
Akut ist rausgekommen, dass dieses OpenSSL eine so schwerwiegende Softwarelücke hat, dass im schlimmsten Fall sogar die geheimen Schlüssel der im Internet befindlichen Server und Web-Server Angreifern in die Hände gefallen sind. Was bedeutet, dass ein Angreifer, der allen Datenverkehr mitgeschnitten hat, rückwirkend mit diesen geheimen Schlüsseln den Datenverkehr wieder entschlüsseln kann. Und damit die gesamte kryptografische Sicherung dieser Verbindung hinfällig geworden ist. Und das ist durch einen Programmierfehler eines deutschen Programmierers passiert, der einfach dort seinen Programmcode in dieses Projekt...
Oh guck mal, schon so spät?
Gut, also ich sehe hier zusammengezogene Gesichter, wilde Handwerker. Und ich denke, im nächsten Chaosradio werden wir uns mal genauer mit diesem komischen Open-Messes-L-Ding beschäftigen. Ich danke allen Leuten, die mitgemacht haben. Ihr könnt gerne auch mal Krach machen, diesmal für euch selbst. Das war das Chaosradio 200 aus der Marienstraße 11 in Berlin aus dem Chaos Computer Club Berlin. Wenn ihr gerade jetzt unterwegs seid, könnt ihr gerne noch vorbeikommen. Hier gibt es nämlich noch ein bisschen Party mit Musik und sogar Getränken, die möglicherweise unter Umständen auch alkoholisch sind, hat man mir zumindest zugemunkelt. Auf Fritz geht es jetzt aus Potsdam weiter mit dem Night Flight mit Flo Heiler. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter und ich hab zum Schluss wie immer nur eins zu sagen. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.